well
roughly what it is
so hi uh
i'm andrea i'm a postdoc with uh mesh
the timezone really is more of a
placeholder
for me to describe my research interests
a bit more broadly
in particular
to those of you who are not already
working in quantum computing
i think there are not so many here
but
hopefully some maybe on zoom
so primarily i'm interested in how we
can leverage quantum information for
cryptography
and as i'm sure you will have uh heard
by now you know quantum computers are
expected you know one day at least in
theory to be able to break uh the
cryptography that we use today
and while this is a bad news for
cryptography
the main message that i want to get
across in this talk is that actually
quantum information more than
compensates
for this in fact it turns out that we
can leverage quantum information to
realize cryptographic tasks that are in
some cases impossible classically and in
other cases realize them from weaker
assumptions than is known possible
so what is it that makes quantum
information so special
for cryptography well at the heart of it
is one simple theorem which is called
the no cloning theorem it's a
consequence of the uncertainty principle
and it says that
sort of a state a quantum state cannot
be generically copied what i mean by
this is
you know classically given a string of
bits you can always make two copies of
it and this is essentially because you
can always read a string without
disturbing it
however in the quantum world there does
not exist a universal copying procedure
that takes as input an arbitrary unknown
quantum state and produces two copies of
it
and so you know this is on the one hand
bad news because it says you know
fundamentally it is hard to store
quantum information
but on the positive side in a
cryptographic setting
this means that you know you're
significantly restricting the possible
strategies that an attacker can perform
and so i guess the plan is to show you a
little bit how
this principle can can help us
and before i do this i think at least a
few of you
uh work in a very different field and
quantum computing so i just wanted to
have one slide to give some essential
information so that the rest
makes a bit more sense
i guess this is at the cost of
saying what a qubit is
uh to those of you who already work in
quantum
so uh you know as you have heard a qubit
is the quantum analog of a bit it can be
in a superposition of zero and 1 here
alpha and beta are complex numbers and
really you should think of this as a
two-dimensional vector
where the standard bases vectors
are 0 and 1. so you can think of 0 as
pointing
upwards and 1 is pointing to the right
and any linear combination of the 2 is a
valid cubit state so for example we
could have
1 over square root of 2 0 plus 1 over
square root of 2 1 this is sort of the
vector pointing to the 45 degree
angle we could have the same state with
a minus sign this would correspond to
minus 45 degree
and one one really important thing is
that really the only way to extract
classical information from a quantum
status via a measurement
so you're allowed to ask the question is
the qubit state zero or one and you will
get an answer if you do so a zero or one
depending on the
the probabilities will depend on the
coefficients alpha and beta now the
crucial difference for quantum
information is that upon measurement the
state will collapse to the outcome that
you observe so you no longer have the
state that you started with this is very
important
and of course you know
you can ask the same question is it zero
one with respect to any other bases
there's nothing special about the the
standard bases and the post-measurement
state will be one of the two orthogonal
basis factors
and so let's see how we can leverage all
of this
so let's consider uh the task of key
distribution
so in key distribution we have two
parties alice and bob they have a simple
goal which is to agree on a uniformly
random secret key this is a secret in
the sense that it's known only to the
two of them
and they would like to do this by
communicating over a public
communication channel this is public in
the sense that any malicious
eavesdropper you can read everything
that passes through the channel
intercept any message
so if you stop and think about this for
a moment you you'll find that it's very
difficult to come up with a key
distribution protocol if you can
intercept
everything
in fact it turns out that it's
impossible classically to realize a key
distribution with unconditional security
so what i mean here by unconditional
security is that the security should be
information theoretic so it should hold
even
against the computationally unbounded
disrupter
and this uh this impossibility is quite
easy to see you know any bit that alice
sends to bob and vice versa can be
intercepted
by eve
like so
and so eventually at the end of any
protocol even bob will have seen exactly
the same transcript so if bob was
supposed to learn a key then so
information theoretically so can
now things are different in the quantum
setting but alice is not restricted to
to just sending bits she can send qubits
for example she could choose to send
qubits in the standard bases or in the
45 minus 45 degree bases but you know
let's say that she chooses to send
a bunch of qubits
and for each qubit she chooses uniformly
at random between these four possible
states
now of course
eve can still intercept each qubit on
the way from alice to bob
and she can try to learn some
information about it okay but the point
is that eve does not know the basis
choice that alice made and so with at
least half probability eve will be
measuring in an incorrect basis and this
measurement as a result will disturb the
state that eventually gets the ball
and so the key is that you know in a
later step alice and bob can reveal to
each other their basis choices
and they can detect with high
probability if eve has tampered with a
significant
fraction of the communication
[Music]
and if so they they will abort the
protocol so so this is really the key
idea here and using this idea
one uh can realize key distribution
quantumly with unconditional security
and this is uh something that we already
knew in 1984
from a protocol of bennett in versailles
so so there is this start contrast
between the quantum and the classical
setting
for key distribution and the natural
question is can we go beyond key
distribution
and uh unfortunately the answer seems to
be no and this is because there there is
another
primitive called bit commitment
which we know to be provably impossible
to realize
with unconditional security even using
quantum information
and unfortunately bit commitment is a
fairly basic primitive in cryptography
it is implied by many other more complex
primitives
and so we seem to be a little bit
out of luck here
and i think it's fair to say that
for for several years over many years
quantum cryptography has focused more on
the study of key distribution in various
seconds
and so what i want to highlight
today is
so the line of research has emerged or
gained traction a bit more recently
which i find
most interesting which is the following
so you know in in almost all of
classical cryptography
or almost all of it is based on
computational hardness assumptions
what i mean by this is that the security
of
almost all cryptographic protocols is
not unconditional but it's based on the
assumed hardness of some computational
problem like for example
computing a discrete logarithm or
factoring
and so why not try to combine quantum
information with computational hardness
in the hope of getting interesting
cryptographic primitives not with
unconditional security
but at least from weaker assumptions
than is possible classically
so let me just state briefly one
one example of this from a recent work
so the primitive is multi-party
computation which is
more powerful than key distribution
it allows actually mutually distrustful
parties to compute an arbitrary function
of their joint inputs securely so this
is very powerful
now classically we know how to build
this based on
various computational assumptions about
specific problems but crucially we do
not know how to build this from one way
functions
so just to remind you a one-way function
is a function that is easy
to compute what is hard to invert on
average
and the existence of one wave functions
is pretty much the minimal uh assumption
that we know to be useful for for
anything in cryptography so ideally we
would like to reduce you know all of our
primitives to one-way functions but this
does not seem to be
the case for multi-party computation in
fact there is a black box sort of
impossibility here
however it turns out that maybe
surprisingly that in the quantum world
we can actually reduce multi-party
computation all the way to the existence
of one way function
y functions and this is due to two
recent concurrent results
so i guess i have one last comment which
is you know in this case multi-party
computation is something that we already
knew how to build just you know
classically just from stronger
assumptions so this is a you know i
would say more of a qualitative
uh result
however there are very interesting
examples where the combination of
computational hardness and quantum
information can really lead to new
primitives that are even out of reach of
what is possible classically
i think cheaper and later we'll talk
about some of this
so
[Music]
so you said
that uh one-way functions imply quantum
multi-party communication are those is
that like one-way functions that are
secure to you know quantum inverters or
yeah
let's say one more question